salut tout le monde donc vous l'avez
compris hein c'est une vidéo qui est
tourné pendant le confinement alors moi
j'ai la chance d'avoir mon appartement
et mes bureaux dans le même bâtiment
donc c'est pour ça que je peux venir
tourner mais je suis tout seul
loïc es tu là et bien non je ne crois
pas famille sheila à
ils concluent ils peuvent vraiment
personne aujourd'hui je vous raconte un
morceau de vie un petit peu fou qui
m'est arrivé on est fin 2016
et cette semaine a été tellement spécial
que j'ai fini par pleurer dans les
toilettes d'un train loïc petit
générique de true story oui je dis true
story alors contrairement à mais est ce
autre trou story habituel où il s'est
passé des trucs plutôt négatif là c'est
des choses assez positive mais un peu
folle et assez folle pour vous est
racontée
je crois qu'on est au mois de novembre
comme ça de 2016 débit novembre moi je
fais un point sur les choses qui va
falloir que je mette en place mon
travail habituel mais aussi des
objectifs ou des espoirs et j'en parle à
ces lignes je lui dis tu sais ce qui
serait vraiment cool là c'est de
vraiment trouver des locaux en fait où
je puisse faire les bureaux où je puisse
commencer à recruter faire le studio etc
mais il faut que ce soit un truc
vraiment proche de la maison en fait
parce que comme je suis toujours en
tournée tout ça c'est trop compliqué si
s'éloigner et il va jamais tu perds ton
temps et puis là je pensais aux
spectacles de rodage
j'aimerais bien trouver des personnes
pour les voix off et j'aimerais beaucoup
demandé aux frères bogdanoff je vous
arrête tout de suite il y en a qui
disent quoi bogdanov ces escrocs alors
outre leur côté ultra médiatique et le
fait que oui dis souvent des bêtises
et c'est ça reste quand même des gens
qui sont passionnés par la singularité
par les sciences et par les maths faut
pas tout mélanger en fait ce sont des
personnes qui sont très intéressantes
bref revenons en à nos moutons et les
beaux tanins ne sont pas des moutons
c'est vraiment ça se saurait bref je me
dis c'est vraiment cool que je puisse
rencontrer les bogdanoff
j'aimerais également à voir ça ce serait
incroyable d'avoir tiré ragueneau qui me
fait la voix off pour le spectacle parce
que thierry ragueneau
c'est la voix française de the mentalist
et tu vois pour le clin d'oeil ce serait
fou et puis je me dis aussi à la
j'aimerais vraiment beaucoup rencontré
bernard werber parce que je sais que lui
quand il écrit ses livres ses romans ses
histoires il utilise en fait une
structure architecturale jeudi
j'aimerais bien un jour le rencontrer et
discuter de ça avec lui parce que ce
serait intéressant d'écrire des
spectacles en s'inspirant de cette
méthodologie en fait quelque chose que
le public ne ressent pas mais qui
existent et qui structurent et qui rend
beau en fait l'ensemble et je me dis
aussi j'aimerais vraiment rencontré
associé à un jour ça va dans la même
discussion que j'ai avec céline et ça
c'est on est genre le lannic quoi tu
vois un petit un petit l'indiquent
tranquille c'était juste des j'adorerais
un jour trois petits points je je
continue à travailler et tout est le
mardi je me lève tôt au chevet ce que
j'ai à faire à l'époque ces jeux fait
encore la une vidéo par jour donc je me
lève à 6h du matin je trouve l'idée du
jour je l'écris je la tourne je la monte
pour qu'elles soient publiées à 17
heures et puis à côté de ça j'ai ma vie
avec les spectacles clair et tout sa
voiture et en général je reste tout le
temps dans le bureau qui a chez moi que
je me suis fait chez moi dans une pièce
et un moment donné j'en ai marre ce jour
là j'en ai vraiment et je lui dis c'est
quoi j'ai besoin de prendre l'air il y
avait des trucs qui n'allait pas c'était
peut-être le montage je vais prendre
l'air je vais à la poste acheter des
timbres un peu et a besoin de temps le
chaînon j'ai pas besoin de table c'est
vraiment pour avoir un but sortir parce
que la poste allait à cinq minutes à
pied d'ici
et ça me fera une petite balade d'un
quart d'heure aller retour ça me fera du
bien quoi et en sortant du bâtiment je
passe devant la porte d'un local qui
était là et je je vois des gens c'est
pas de local c'est pas les personnes qui
habituellement dans des gens qui
visitent plein de monde jeudi mais
attendait depuis quand c'est évident ici
et donc j'écoute je rentre pas chrosômes
au dos et a loué je vous dis rien mais
ça serait énorme
c'est à settat littéralement 15 secondes
de ma porte d'entrée
tu vois je traverse un couloir et j'y
suis je me dis c'est incroyable il faut
vraiment que je chope ces trucs donc
j'attends que les visites se termine je
ne le rendent pas en même temps tout le
monde une fois que tout le monde part
jeudi au mais qu'est ce que c'est
possible de visiter une fièvre est donc
je visite
bon c'est un spoil naturel c'est les
locaux où je suis maintenant et puis à
la fin je dis pas voilà je suis super
intéressé je vais le prendre tous les
midis doivent déposer le dossier et tous
et moi je ferais si je vous dépose le
dossier dans une heure parce que c'est
bon et je sais que j'ai une force à ce
moment là par rapport aux autres c'est à
dire que les autres sont en train de
créer leur entreprise et cherchent un
endroit - la boîte elle existe déjà à
l'est déjà structuré et c'est un passif
on appelle ça avoir un passif donc donc
c'est intéressant quoi tu vois je lui
file les papiers j'ai confirmation dès
le lendemain matin et je chope le bureau
que je disais vouloir avoir le lundi
près de chez moi vous armer c'est trop
dur je le trouve le mardi et le mercredi
et ces signes quoi tu vois les sas était
complètement dingue c'est pas fini parce
que le mercredi je reçois un mail d'une
personne qui travaille avec bernard
werber qui dit bah voilà il ya le
nouveau livre de bernard qui va sortir
vous aviez parlé une fois il ya très
longtemps dans vos vidéos début de
l'année d'un de ses livres et je me suis
peut-être ça vous intéresse et de le
recevoir et tout reçoit le livre est en
fait je reçois également un message sur
twitter de bernard werber une seule qui
me dit merci beaucoup pour eux ce que tu
avais fais ce que tu avais dit sur mes
livres le toit et tous je dis [ __ ]
c'est ouf c'est pour moi bernard werber
faut bien se dire que je le lis depuis
1991 quand il a sorti les fournit c'est
le seul auteur où je sais que tous les
ans je suis ce qui va sortir quoi qu'il
arrive
et donc on discute un tout petit peu je
dis mais moi j'adorerais faire une vidéo
avec vous quoi sur youtube un jour en
maths interne
il me répond moi je me paie le luxe de
ne jamais me déplacer donc si tu es prêt
à venir jusqu'à chez moi y'a pas de ceux
ci est ce que je suis prêt à me déplacer
durant et peut-être
heures pour aller voir un auteur que je
dis depuis presque vingt ans je crois
que oui fier je crois que oui donc je
suis allé chez lui marc aussi chez lui
très gentiment et on a fait une
interview de 20 minutes pendant 3h ou 4h
un truc comme ça et c'était juste
incroyable du coup j'ai pu poser toutes
les questions que je voulais poser et où
saadi c'est vraiment une relation se
dire que aujourd'hui on est on est
devenu amis ont fait des loups garous
ensemble en ont déjà un ensemble non etc
c'est juste foutu c'est dans ces moments
de vie où j'ai failli checker mon moi
petit comme sa meilleure beaucoup trop
cool tu vois et donc ça c'est le
mercredi mais c'est pas fini en fait
parce que le jeudi quand même je me dis
tu sais quoi je vais envoyer un mail sur
un site de d'imprésario dont on sait pas
bien ce que c'est pour essayer de
joindre thierry ragueneau proposant de
projets parce que ma foi c'est ça reste
un travail tu vois de farine doivent
donc donc j'en vois juste ça et nous on
part quand je dis nous c'est diablo et
moi mon régisseur lumière on part à
angers donc on est jeudi ont par angers
on pas rangé pour faire un spectacle
pour une association qui s'appelle
ecrennes go que je défends depuis des
années donc c'est un spectacle où je
vais faire gratuitement évidemment et
diablo que je salue ici au travers de
cette vidéo
je le remercie d'accepter de travailler
gratuitement pour moi ce jour là parce
que le but c'est qu'on fasse un maximum
de recettes pour les donner à
l'association qui aide les orphelins en
ukraine
je vais pas je fais beaucoup de choses
en fait que je raconte pas parce que ce
serait très prétentieux de vouloir
mettre ça en avant mais ça ça fait voilà
partie des assauts que je défends c'est
pas que je les défends parce que j'en
parle pas énorme publiquement mais je
préfère faire les actions en fait plutôt
que d'en parler et donc on part là bas
on comprend la route pour aller là bas
ont fait le spectacle se passe très bien
et c'est pareil le lendemain il ya un
autre truc qu'on fait aussi pour une
partie des enfants ukrainiens qui sont
présents ce genre
donc on est vendredi maintenant et le
vendredi matin je reçois un appel de
thierry ragueneau donc c'est un peu
comme si tu as the mentalist qui
t'appelle tu vois donc j'ai vraiment
clairement de bugs et je suis amoureux
des voix je suis amoureux des voix off
j'ai la chance aussi de connaître
philippe et véronique qui font les voix
de homer et marge tu vois c'est assez
fascinant pour moi tout ça est donc
thierry m'appelle mouche comme un gamin
et tout et on se met d'accord sûr sûr
sûr le projet de faire les voix off pour
mon spectacle et ça c'est juste
incroyable tu vois thierry
m'appelle et me dit mais je suis ravi
d'avoir au téléphone parce que j'adore
le mentalisme je lui il a passé
apparemment un énorme kif en fait à
faire la sienne il a adoré faire le
comédien sur sur la voie française parce
qu'attention les les voix off ce sont
des comédiens en fait ils font un rôle
de comédien c'est extrêmement difficile
il faut savoir jouer vraiment à mort
pour pouvoir doubler quelqu'un tu vois
et donc lille a pris un petit énorme à
faire ça et il adore le mentalisme les
spectacle de mentalisme
il accepte de faire la voix off et pour
la petite histoire il est venu aussi
voir le spectacle à l'olympia après
quand il ya la grande première
officielle il était juste à côté de mes
parents qui était juste trop content
d'être à côté de vie tu vois donc ça
c'est incroyable c'est le vendredi matin
ma piaule d'hôtel mais c'est pas fini
le soir après tant et fais tout ça on va
pour prendre le train à la gare d'angers
avec diablo prendre son train pour le
crochet lui rentre chez lui et moi pour
mon train pour paris il ya un bouddha et
sur le quai de la gare devant la gare il
y à igor et grichka bogdanov qui sand et
je me dis voilà la vie est folle en fait
la vie allait complètement folle
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai formulée le
lundi il ya tout est en train de se
passer là dans la semaine j'ai une
émotion particulière kelly en plus à la
fatigue et c'est fou et je m'approche de
leur maison avec eux deux c'est
l'opportunité c'est le moment est plus
m'approche de coups je vois qu'ils sont
en discussion avec deux personnes
je me dis bah en fait non c'est vraiment
pas le moment en fait ils sont vraiment
en train de discuter et j'ai arrivé
comme un cheveu sur la soupe
et en plus de leur dire bonjour j'ai une
demande à formuler mais je vais trop
relou donc c'est pas grave le moment il
est passé il rappelait deux occasions
dans ma vie et puis c'est comme ça quoi
tu vois sachant que je les avais déjà
croisé il ya quelques années quand
c'était en 2013 comme ça au plus grand
cabaret du monde
ce qu écrivait un texte
jeff pas d'un club pour son passage et
du coup on s'était vus là-bas donc bon
bref je trace ma route et je vais
prendre mon train et puis dans le train
je m'installe et je sort un bouquin ça
s'appelle des épreuves non corrigées que
du coup bernard werber m'a fait envoyer
et que j'ai eues jeudi matin juste avant
de partir angers je vous fais voir ce
que c'est
d'ailleurs les épreuves non corrigées ça
c'est les épreuves non corrigées depuis
l'au delà
c'est à dire c'est carré quasiment la
version définitive mais il n'y a pas
encore eu les dernières corrections qui
ont été appliqués et donc tu tu reçois
ça pour la presse souvent reçoit ça et
tout est donc moi j'avais reçu sadler
par la part de bernard et son équipe et
c'était juste fou zazie de recevoir ça
en avant première le livre est tout
quelques mois avant la sortie et donc je
m'installe à ma place dans le train et
je commence à dire ça et donc je suis se
rappelle les places isolé vous savez il
ya une place le couloir et de place et
par nous fais ta jeu je perçois dans la
vision périphérique
une jeune femme qui accroupi et tous et
qui visiblement est en train de faire
une photo donc je regarde pro une fois
qu'elle part je tourne la tête quand
même pour par curiosité quoi en fait le
temps que je montais que je m'installais
que je me mette à lire et quand je lis
en peluche dans ma bulle
il ya deux personnes qui sont installées
sur les deux sièges vides ici mais
j'avais pas vu et donc je tourne la tête
et je regarde et je tombe face à face
mais vraiment les yeux dans les yeux
avec al grichka bogdanoff et je dis
bonjour effet bonjour je veux vous me
reconnaissez pas c'est normalement s'est
vu il ya quelques années au plus grand
cabaret du monde
fm si si peut-être me dit quelque chose
ce qui est complètement faux
à ce moment là c'est juste élégant où
vous bienveillant de sa part mais c'est
pas possible et on se met à discuter
comme ça pendant 20 min tu vois sur le
trajet et je dis ce que je fais tout à
fait à me serais super qu'on puisse
prendre un thé parce qu'on bolt et avec
asher dieu super combi se voir et
discuter ensemble expérience mais oui
carrément un tout et je parle vite fait
du projet n'est fait mais oui carrément
on parler d'accord il devrait on serait
ravi de faire ça et tout est donc on a
fait ça dont ils ont fait les voix off
du spectacle bénévolement plus
gracieusement en toute sympathie et tout
on a déjeuné ensemble à prix d'été
ensemble on a discuté passionnément de
plein de sujets et c'était trop cool la
fin de ces 20 minutes de conversation je
pense aussi que c'est lié à la fatigue
j'ai été obligé de me lever et d'aller
aux toilettes et pleurer alors oui je
vous vois dans les commentaires vous
foutent de ma gueule
eh bien eh bien je suis un petit être
sensible je suis un fragile qu'est ce
que tu veux tu vois c'est ça le fragile
j'ai vécu peut-être une des plus belles
semaines de ma vie entame de surprise
soit parce que c'est des gens qui sont
connus ou cocasses et c'est vraiment
tout ce que j'avais en espoirs le lundi
de projeter un jour peut-être dans ma
vie sans savoir comment pourquoi et si
c'était réalisable ou pas tout s'est
passé la même semaine en enchaînements
et je suis rentré et j'ai passé un week
end us est un peu haute perchée quoi je
sais faire sur un nuage vous allez me
dire il ya un truc qui ne s'est pas
passé c'est alexandre astier oui c'est
vrai ça c'est pas passé et c'est un peu
mon jedi ans dans le travail à c'est un
mec que je respecte en tant qu'homme et
en tant que créatif et donne un jour je
le rencontrerai tu vois alors là je
crois que si j'ai chialé déjà une fois
qui a tout ça qui s'est passé je sais
pas ce qui se serait passé si j'avais
rencontré astier et qu'on avait discuté
ensemble comme à chaque fois dans l'est
dans les trous story je raconte des
choses qui sont plutôt négatifs
peut-être cool de raconter cette semaine
folle qui m'était arrivé genre j'en
avais parlé en deux ou trois bris dans
quelques interviews ces dernières années
mais là vous avez tout ce qui s'est
passé d'un coup cette semaine là dans
l'ordre chronologique
si vous ne connaissiez pas ma chaîne je
m'appelle fabien olicard vous pouvez
vous abonner c'est gratuit activer la
cloche pour voir les nouvelles vidéos et
là je vous mets deux vidéos à côté de
moi il y en a une c'est une eau story où
je me suis tout fait voler par les
douaniers au pérou et une autre au story
où j'ai failli mourir en voiture avec
mon pote philippe ça c'est très vieille
trop storia d'ailleurs donc peut-être
vous l'avez pas vu de ce qu'elle date de
2016 et là qu'est la vidéo si ça si ça
vous a plu
racontez moi vos plus belles semaines
nous vos plus belles surprises de vie un
peu de positif dans cette période dans
l'espace commentaire j'ai fait des trucs
un peu hasardeux et tout mais qui vous
ont rendu fou d'émotion je serai ravi de
lire ça et j'en partageraient sûrement
sur instagram instagram qui s'affiche là
vous pouvez me rejoindre parce que tous
les jours je partage masse chose
beaucoup à très bientôt ciao